all right buddy what do you got for me
ex-wife's story is x or ex-girlfriend
ex-girlfriend ex-girlfriend all right so
tell me what happened
before we begin i must say um
norwegian is my language so english is
not my first language do you live oslo
or
um close christian son which is the
southernmost uh city i met
i met two girls in cuba that were
professional volleyball players from
oslo
uh back in my 20s good time yeah
volleyball players man
they're a lot of fun norwegian girls are
tall dude they're like
yes um you know they're tall chicks but
anyway go ahead we're tall people yeah
yeah
i'm actually uh five foot seven i've
just converted to imperial here five
points
which isn't which isn't tall so i'm i'm
kind of uh struggling with that okay all
right so what happened with the x yeah
so what happened was uh she's a very
beautiful girl we uh
we joined the same friend group when we
started school
tweet three years ago
at the time i was now i'm 30 i look
young i know but at the time i was 27
and she was 21 so she was like perfect
range for me
really
liked her and um but
what's interesting is that in the in the
beginning she was
basically invisible
to me or
i didn't see her and i don't think she
saw me uh but when she was interested in
me basically
it was like gravity just pulling me
towards her so sorry she she wasn't
interested in you is that what you're
saying like she was frigid
i think she was interested to
uh to begin with like she she liked my
charisma but she had a boyfriend at the
time and
oh look at her right
yeah
but you know we started to hang out and
even though she had a boyfriend um
she started hanging out with me um
in the evenings and you know we were
watching movies at my place and uh
i i tried to tell her like i don't want
to
um
make you into the kind of person who
who does this with someone who's not
your boyfriend you see i i didn't want
her to betray her boyfriend but
she uh didn't care about that she was
let me just let me just stop you for a
second because there's something that
that
men need to understand about women
there really are no single women
okay
that's true
well
what i mean by that is every woman that
you're talking to like any woman that
you're interested in that you know that
you look at that you want to be intimate
with that you want to form whatever
level of relationship that you want to
form with she's already dealing with
other guys
usually guys like i'm going to say
plural minimum guy she might be married
i've i've come across lots of married
women on dating apps
okay
that's usually where they go um you know
they don't
they don't like to talk to you or go to
the nightclub so they don't get caught
so they could be married they could be
engaged that could be somebody's fiance
they could be a girlfriend they could be
talking to a guy and dating him for
three weeks they could be talking to
five guys and dating them for several
weeks each
they could have thirsty betas up in
their dms talking to them constantly hey
let me send you some flowers to work
there was something i shared on twitter
earlier today
right guys like hey i've been talking to
this girl for four months and uh i want
to send her flowers at work but she
won't tell me where she works it's like
dude she's not interested like she's
like she wants nothing to do with you
but all women have the attention of
other guys so whenever you're saying so
no single women you mean that she has 99
plus messages she's got she's got
something going on i mean she could be
on one end of the spectrum married on
the other spectrum she's just dating a
lot of guys or talking a lot of guys or
any combination of those things so
anytime you get with a girl you're
poaching her from another guy
i feel good about that you
know so you're talking to the girlfriend
and what happened with your situation
yeah she breaks up with him and uh she
she um
she's basically about to get into it
with another guy and i tell her like hey
i don't want you another guy that's not
you
yeah okay and i tell her i don't want
you to get with him i want you to get
with me and so she gets with me because
i don't know i guess i'm the better
option
so
so hold on a second let me just stop you
there for a sec now you're negotiating
desire because her because her
um
every fiber of her being is picking the
other guy
and you're trying to convince her to
pick you instead which she does so what
did you tell her to pick you over the
other guy
i think in that case she was interested
in both me and the other guy and
she had already been on this hiking trip
and kissed the other guy i guess they
were doing it too
okay but i basically said to her like yo
you don't want that guy you want to be
with someone like me and i
showed her my merits as it were uh
how did you show her your marriage did
you did you have like a powerpoint
presentation with all your pros and cons
uh no we were um
bike we were biking in the evening uh
it's very dark here in the winter but we
were biking and uh i told her like
here's my future plan this is my
education behind me and my plans before
me
and this is what i want to become and i
think you are more interested in that
than this young younger less experienced
man and she said uh she thought about it
and a day later was there an age
difference between you and her
yes i am 30 now and she is 24 now so
she's seven years my
junior and how long ago did this happen
three years ago yeah she's in her party
years dude like she just wants to party
yeah i i age like after high school till
about 27 women just want to see the
world travel with their girlfriends
party go to the nightclubs go to the
foam cannon party [ __ ] like that like
that's generally what they want to do
about that i have a question for you how
do you reconcile
this that the girls have the partiers in
that age and that they are
also at the prime of their um
reproductive capacity and they
you know
well you live in a very feminist country
like isn't it very yeah egalitarian
there it is right big time yeah it's you
you're uh
yeah so promiscuity is kind of you know
the norm in you know the nordic
countries right like you know women just
kind of bang whoever they want i
remember they did this social experiment
where once where they had um
they had a woman in um
sorry they had a guy in north america at
a large city something like chicago just
in open square and he's asking all these
women
he's doing a cold approach i like you
let me get your number you want to have
sex with me right now
and
every single one of them said no and
this guy was pretty good looking they
took the same guy and they put him
somewhere in a nordic country that's
more left-leaning that's more feminist
and i think it was something like it was
a fairly significant you know percentage
it was definitely way more than zero uh
when we were like yes let's go right now
it's totally bank right so it's like you
know you can't really expect to find
women that are not promiscuous in a
country like that that have got a notch
count that are going to want to be like
oh this you know like i'm 23 years old
i'm the most fertile right now so i
should i should get with norwegian
because he has all of these merits that
that's not what they're thinking
at all well i don't i don't have uh so
many merits currently i mean i have a
lot of merits but uh
so the
what happened was that i
uh
became it's like she just uh sucked the
life out of me she just drained me of
energy over time
it's hard to say she had a troubled
childhood and upbringing she was there
were so many red flags like a communist
parade as you say okay
um and i should have seen them and in
hindsight you know it's 20 20 but um
well i mean like here's here's what the
benefit of knowing the red flags is now
is you're not going to invite a woman
like that into your life you're not
going to tell her to break her up with
her boyfriend you're not going to tell
her to pick you over the other guy you
might you might have some fun with her
but you're not going to invite her into
your life you're not going to like do
this big sales pitch with a powerpoint
yeah i was pedestalizing her big time
and you know i found your work two years
ago when things were really going
downhill and your work has helped me so
much so thank you for that good so how
did it end for you
well uh i'd say that like we got
together in february and already in may
i was gonna leave and go do a summer
work somewhere else in the country and
and i said to her like i don't think
this is working out
she became very attached to me
and
we basically went there together she
came with me of all things she really
came with me
things were going downhill and i broke
it up with her uh
february
so we were together for one year and
then i broke it off we had no contact
until
the summer of
last year and then we kind of picked it
up and so it sounds like that was a
while ago like what are you doing today
in your world
i'm writing my thesis a master's thesis
but
for theology i'm studying to become a
pastor
okay a pastor
so you're so you're looking for mother
of your kids sort of thing oh yeah big
time uh i'm 30 and uh you know i'm
almost at the end of my education so i'm
looking forward to get a can you get a
nun out of the convent and you know
your wife
i'm a part of a christian subculture in
norway and for sure it's um
there are a lot of girls here who have
zero notches and uh
that are chased so they exist
all right well that's always your best
bet right i mean if you want to make uh
you know make a woman the mother of your
kids one of the most important things
you got to do is you got to kind of
uncover her past and make sure she
doesn't have
a peppered past with a whole bunch of
notches right because we know that women
divorce men and leave men um when
they've been promiscuous you also have
higher instances of mental disorders
abortions you know all kinds of other
stuff so you definitely don't want to
invite that in your life but you already
know that now
yes so uh it ended oh sorry uh
yeah basically it ended horribly and uh
now i'm trying to rebuild myself so i
had a question about confidence
rebuilding but okay go ahead yes
question
uh sorry go ahead and ask a question
okay i i don't want to take up more of
your time than necessary you've already
given me so much but um
how do i
get the confidence to hit the gym like i
used to i i've gained 46
pounds you don't you don't need
confidence to go to the gym you just
need will
you just need willpower okay you just
have to look at yourself in the mirror
and [ __ ]
yell at yourself and say that you're
disgusting fat [ __ ]
you need to fix it basically that's what
i do dude like i probably put on maybe
10 pounds over this last winter
okay and i'm working on getting it off
like i'm normally jacked like i'm
usually ripped and it's like i like i've
got a one pack right now instead of a
six-pack
so i'm trying i'm trying to deal with
that and you know how do i deal with it
it's like you know i look at myself and
i'm like dude you look [ __ ] bad right
it's like i gotta eat better i gotta
move more i'm gonna hit the dojo harder
i'm going to add an extra day during the
week it's because i want it bad enough
right yes and it's like you're right if
you want something you're going to find
a way if you don't want it you're going
to find an excuse it's a symbol true is
it true all right yeah okay thank you
very much all right buddy get your ass
in there do the work see ya hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you